ce matin c'est bon Jean-François Copé
Bonjour bonjour merci beaucoup
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale bonjour bonjour
de la France bien sûr parler de
ça
a été
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on est tous
les
vaccins la seule chose que je puisse
vous dire c'est que depuis la première
seconde j'ai considéré qu'on devait être
derrière le gouvernement dans la
vie
dans ce domaine-là on peut pas se payer
le luxe d'être là et les autres chacun
dans notre coin donc moi je préfère Siri
à plomb ça comme on veut mais après je
me méfie toujours des comparaisons
national c'était pour la guerre 14-18 si
vous avez visité le musée de la Grande
Guerre du Pays de Meaux voulais vraiment
pas la même chose que c'était
aujourd'hui à partir de quand
est-ce que c'est encore le cas sur cette
5e
[Musique]
aux aéroports ce qui n'est pas toujours
le cas il compris
mais c'est pas parce que c'est vrai que
parfois on est un peu surpris quand on
arrive la paye est rangé dans les
aéroports de le Francilien on se dit
dans ce domaine là c'est bien trop long
et pas toujours bien organisée
donc il faudrait
que
c'est aujourd'hui
c'est pour ça que moi je suis toujours
occupé parce que je me dis
qu'ils ne sont pas aujourd'hui
par la décision qu'ils ont pris
conduisent des minions de français il
n'ira plus que vous le savez cela va
aussi toucher des personnes qui sont
vaccinés dans une bien moindre mesure
heureusement mais quand même ça vient
s'ajouter à la gestion de santé publique
je pense que après on est sur les mots à
partir du moment où pour pouvoir se
déplacer normalement
[Musique]
crac crac parce que vous avez vu que
quand même on a le nombre de
participants avec un moral hâtivement
limité quand même donc c'est pas c'est
pas une dynamique considérable
la différence et là je crois que c'est
maintenant après
ça c'est la première fois qu'on a une
génération c'est la première fois qu'on
ne voit plus les trois personnalités
dans l'ordre dans le désordre a Juppé
Sarkozy-Fillon depuis la fin des années
80 avec un steak
c'est la première fois qu'on a une
nouvelle génération
[Musique]
je vous disais que je suis plutôt
rassuré elle se fait sans haine et et on
l'a vu entre des candidats qui ont
défendu comme leurs différents
deuxième marqueur de cette primaire
c'est que c'est que le leader que nous
avons choisi et une jeune femme qui a le
parcours qu'on lui connaît une
expérience elle a été ministre est
président de région je d'ailleurs je ne
sais pas ce qui est le mieux pour
diriger la France parce que c'est vrai
que l'expérience de terrain est
irremplaçable et quand tout état de
cause c'est un vrai plus par rapport à
Emmanuel Macron je parle même pas des
candidats extrémistes que c'est un vrai
plus et je me dis en plus facile
personnel mais ça c'est un combat moi
que je mène depuis très longtemps si la
France avait à la tête de la République
une femme ce serait formidable
Nicolas Sarkozy
je sais pas
Valérie Pécresse
bien bien longtemps que je suis je ne
suis absolument les propos des autres
[Musique]
du moment où elle est notre candidate
elle va porter nos couleurs il faut se
ranger derrière elle bien sûr pour le
coup ça c'est bon
cette belle photo de famille samedi au
tout le monde était réuni et puis
derrière elle a lancé son
opposition
ça veut dire quoi
[Musique]
j'ai fait un très joli coup que personne
n'avait venir donc dans la vie il faut
toujours connaître les choses bois il a
pris le créneau par rapport aux 4
candidats il a pris le créneau
de ce des militants qui rêve d'une
alliance avec l'extrême nord et comme il
était seul sur ce créneau il a forcément
[Musique]
évidemment c'est
pas non plus 70 % et
tout à l'heure
et
respecter
un petit peu
[Musique]
en tout cas vous savez c'est une
histoire complexe la relation donc on va
dire que voilà ça doit se c'est une
manière de faux pour avoir des dettes
monte d'un cran dans cette dans cette
relation extrêmement tendu entre cela
étant cela étant y a derrière ça une
attente de droite très très ferme sur
les sujets d'autorité j'ai moi-même un
vide inventé il y a quelques années
Concept il y a d'ailleurs repris
fréquemment de droite décomplexé
avec lui
[Musique]
c'est une
étanchéité absolue avec l'extrême droite
que cette extrême droite soit incarné
par Le Pen ou pas et moi c'est
exactement la même chose donc
et donc ce que je veux dire c'est que il
ne faut pas perdre notre cap pourquoi
parce que un nous avons besoin de tout
le monde et je pense que Éric Ciotti on
est parfaitement conscient à bailleur
Valérie et il lui vont se voir je crois
aujourd'hui il aura l'occasion de se
parler tout ça ils vont même déjeuner
ensemble et et je suis absolument
persuadé que pour toute une série de
raison il y aura un alignement complet
d'intérêt entre parce que c'est parce
que c'est l'intérêt de la France c'est
que il y a un moment où il faut avoir ça
en tête et puis deuxièmement ça va
peut-être pour ça que je dis ça mais
paradoxalement je pense que la clé de
cette élection elle est chez les
électeurs de droite qui ont voté Macron
en 2017 c'est-à-dire que si nous sommes
très ferme sur les question d'autorité
de telle manière que nous préserve ion
les électeurs de droite qui veulent de
la sécurité et que dans le même temps on
a un discours de modernité de progrès de
plus ou moins avec enthousiasme
pour toutes les raisons souviens en
terme de progrès économique de progrès
social de progrès scientifique de tout
ce qui fait la grandeur de la France à
ce moment-là on a deux piliers solide
l'autorité d'un côté le progrès de
l'autre et ce qui aujourd'hui apparaît
part c'est pour certains comme un petit
trou de souris à la droite ils
arriveront pas tout d'un coup ça
s'élargit et ça devient une opportunité
pour la France
de la
connexion à une condition c'est que on
soit solide sur les questions
régaliennes
sécurité justice immigration domaines
dans lesquels pour toute une série de
raison Emmanuel Macron était défaillant
parce que c'est pas son histoire c'est
pas sa culture et tu as jamais été élu
local il n'a jamais senti c'est
parce qu'il est en train de prendre
du score qu'on appuie ici ou la réaliser
vous dire c'est que voilà ce qui serait
plus c'est la même chose
que les autres l'importance de
pas attendu longtemps
il en a parlé
des républicains beaucoup ont été
représenté par mon ami Éric Ciotti
[Applaudissements]
et parmi nous parmi nous à nos côtés
pour la France
et
le risque quand on fait un peu du côté
de l'extrême droite c'est
le problème c'est que
il est
[Musique]
mets des vérités sont les deux sans
avoir jamais vu de Savigny un électeur
ni un français ni à quartier difficile
que je dis simplement voilà maintenant
il faut qu'on la fin de la récréation
par rapport à
les Français sont des
et politique
de
Marine Le Pen
mais je pense que
déconnecter de la réalité des choses
en fait il a construit son système sur
finalement les grands auteurs de
l'extrême droite du 19e siècle quand on
regarde c'est-à-dire que on identifie
des peurs Charles Maurras paraissent
très bien fait à l'époque c'était
horrible mais c'était très efficace mon
d'identifier les peurs on joue sur les
peurs auprès des Français et pour ça on
identifie les deux me répondent du 19e
siècle c'était les Italiens Zola les
Juifs Dreyfus et puis et puis à ce
moment là on parle du Grand remplacement
qui va envahir la société la
civilisation la société il a exactement
le même ressort aujourd'hui c'est moi
bien sûr que l'immigration et un point
majeur mais il faut l'avoir sous 2 ans
ce qui arrive en France il y a aussi
ceux qui en fait ne sont plus des
immigrés il habite en France depuis 1 2
3 Générations simplement c'est l'échec
complet de l'intégration voir de
l'assimilation mais sauf que moi je vous
en parle j'ai pas attendu gémonies un
certain nombre de mes amis pour le
dénoncer ce qui va pas c'est qu'on a
calé et là où effectivement le discours
de Valérie Pécresse sera absolument
essentiel c'est qu'elle arrive à
convaincre les Français qui ont été
profondément déçu parce qu'il avait
beaucoup d'attente sur ce que nous
étions susceptible de faire notamment
entre 2007 et 2012 que cette fois on
calera pas on ne parlera pas sur un
certain nombre de mesures qui rendent
pays trop attractive sur le plan social
quand vous avez la prise en charge
gratuite de tous les soins sans
exception pour les étrangers en
situation illégale alors que les
Français ou les étrangers réguliers pays
des franchises c'est incompréhensible
lorsque vous avez une incapacité de
reconduire à la frontière dans des
délais rapide ou à statuer rapidement
sur la situation de gens qui sont en
situation illégale ce n'est pas possible
et je peux si tu es comme ça sans
d'exemple sur lesquels on doit prendre
des mesures c'est exactement ce que j'ai
dit il y a 31 ans moi j'ai pas
franchement
c'est pas tout à fait vrai
j'ai l'impression que on est en 90 91
pour lui rendre service de
raconter n'importe quoi
que Jacques Chirac
[Musique]
est la construction de la
France
et moyens considérables nous avions
besoin
de la même manière
et décision
je pense exemple en matière de politique
des banlieues avec la rue je peux
emporter témoignage on a cassé des tours
avec des moyens considérables c'est la
droite qui l'a fait des ghettoïser
apaiser sécuriser un donc sauf que j'ai
jamais envie de montrer ce qui marche
parce que ça casse sur l'affaire comme
tous les gens comme de l'extrême un
problème est résolu et ça devient un
problème pour la France devient
souvenir que
jamais
et on peut tout et n'importe quoi
et je suis désolé de te voir
aujourd'hui
c'est moi qui fait l'intérêt de la loi
de la burqa en France c'est moi qui
dénoncer les comportements dans les
quartiers j'ai même écrit sur le racisme
antiblanc
et moi je vais pas supporter je ne vais
pas en tout cas
je vais plus loin dans le cas précis de
ce qu'il a dit à propos de et également
de ces pauvres
et
l'antisémitisme
que vous avez employé le mot
d'étanchéité tout à l'heure il y a
dans
[Musique]
une famille qui vont
très bien
il était avec Xavier Bertrand
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je fasse
de
gouvernement et
qu'est-ce qui se passe vous avez Macron
qui a plutôt bien un carnet la dimension
de progrès il faut le reconnaître sinon
sinon on se connaît de mauvaise foi dans
un certain de domaine sauf qui n'a pas
fait de réforme et nous avions besoin de
serrer fort il ne les a pas fait et
deuxièmement que ça défaillance c'est la
sécurité la manière dont tu il n'a pas
été capable de gérer la crise des gilet
jaune qui ont bloqué ce pays pendant
plus d'un an et
de 7 de son rapport compliqué et
difficile impossible même avec la avec
l'État qui assure la protection des
Français
il est exactement issu de la même
famille de famille politique que moi
dans la vie d'ailleurs on a des
relations qui sont des relations
amicales tout ça c'est malheureusement
c'est de bonne nuit on va rentrer on va
rentrer dans la période la les noms
d'oiseaux quand même circuler violemment
la vérité c'est que quelques soient les
hommes ou les femmes qui sont en charge
qui sont pas charger une réalité
aujourd'hui c'est que nous ne pourrons
pas tenir durablement avec un tel niveau
alors une urgence absolue s'est barré
est issu de la crise sanitaire c'est une
réalité qu'il fallait assumer au regard
de l'urgence de la situation
est pas de la crise sanitaire et qui est
un espèce de courbe de croissance
permanence de la dépense publique et des
impôts il faut impérativement enrayer 7
cours de dépenses publiques alors on
peut faire semblant de dire ça n'a
aucune importance c'est pas vrai la
vérité c'est que si nous ne voyons pas
les pires danger parce que c'est du
fonctionnement la plupart du temps pour
voir le coût de fonctionnement l'État
qui considérable et que ce coup de
fonctionnement doit être réduit au
bénéfice de l'investissement pour
l'avenir investissement structurel dans
le domaine de la re localisation
industrielle pour notre indépendance
stratégie
investissement scientifique
nous avons des domaines extraordinaire
de développement seulement si on veut y
parvenir il faut faire des économies et
permettent aux entreprises privées de se
développer les ponctionner comme nous le
faisons et quand tu entreprise je dois
le dire aussi des Français qui paye
beaucoup trop d'impôt au regard de la
pouvoir d'achat
[Musique]
sur Mélenchon tout ça et tout ça est
très triste mais montre aussi qu'il y a
des millions de Français aujourd'hui qui
sont un peu perdue et qui attend des
vrais message alors aujourd'hui bah ils
ont peux te l'envoyer tout balader quand
on veut tout envoyer balader en mode
pour un extremiste quand on veut que ça
marche on va tu pourrais partir
gouvernement c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
que le niveau d'indulgent c'est pas le
même parce que quand vous êtes partis de
dans un partis de gouvernement vous
perdre on passera rien vous faites une
erreur de chiffres et vous vous trompez
sur le prix du pain au chocolat vous
prenez de
la vie politique nationale
[Musique]
c'est pas que ça m'a pas convaincu c'est
que moi je connais mon histoire de
France et que j'invite les Françaises et
les Français quel que soit leur niveau
d'agacement de ne jamais tomber dans les
sirènes de l'extrémisme parce que quand
la boîte de Pandore est ouverte on peut
plus la fermer merci beaucoup merci
Jean-François Copé
[Musique]